just want to test can you guys hear my
mic right now
just put in the chat if you can hear me
and i'm gonna unmute
no wait there's uh oh yeah you're right
you're right okay
all right
and welcome back to the realist live
stream in the dunya
we are joined again with the man himself
man the man that started this entire
mess
how are you doing sheikh alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah i'm good
all right guys we gotta we gotta give a
quick disclaimer by the way we gotta do
a mic check right
i did them i did my own mic check can
you guys you did a nice job guys can you
guys hear us can you hear fire
i can increase i can increase the volume
here
they want to hear it crisp bro the other
one here
they're going to want to hear this one
they're definitely going to want to hear
this one listen i want to give a quick
disclaimer right now this is not an
enticement of violence harassment
bullying uh threats we don't want to
hear out that you know because of you
guys we did this to don or we send him
this message we don't want to get any of
this smoke listen the reality is we sent
him a message we sent him a dm it was a
very kind cordial dm right we offered
him to come on this stream with us have
a conversation like human beings but
instead he didn't read the message don
if you're watching this
we just have a question for you you've
been going on streams on your channel
every single day
people are are messaging us they send me
the link i click on it
you have a title that doesn't have
anything to do with islam so it shows
you started the stream with the
intention of talking about something
and then eventually you start talking
bad about islam
and you start talking crap
and then two hours later it's deleted
like
i don't understand this bro like if
you're going to say it why are you
deleting it you know but
unfortunately you had you had to you
know ask for this smoke so
man is going to deliver today inshallah
look before we even start i just want to
say we want good for you don in case you
watched this or somebody sent you the
clip but we want good for you uh we want
you to be guided towards the truth we
want you to follow what is truth and we
we feel that you are sincere
in the fact that you do want to find the
truth but maybe
the way you're going about it is
incorrect instead of having a discussion
face to face instead of talking it
through just making streams and watching
islamophobes by the way all those people
that you watched and you talk about
watching i've already debated them face
to face and you can go watch those
debates on the one message foundation
channel you can see how they fell apart
i gotta
i think got a
little uh sound but anyway so
so if you if you really want to know the
truth we're we're inviting you right now
jump on
even if you want to come in during the
half the show and we'll have a civil
conversation with evidences with
references that you can look up bring
your references if you want to bring in
your little friends apes or mr hammer
time earning them bring them we're right
here live bring it
on just in case you know there's no
misinterpretation
how you can get back to us is just go on
your phone find the dm thread the
message that we sent you at the three
muslims and just reach out we'll make it
happen bro we don't want any excuses
after this
but without further ado rami why don't
you uh play the first clip this manila
all right and by the way guys for anyone
wondering daniel hkikachu will be on the
stream inshallah within an hour
inshallah inshallah
let me
just
while i get this up
give the viewers a short break just so i
can pull it up here
in the meantime i want to say to don
very respectfully
um i understand that it might be
difficult
being a new
you know revert to a convert to a
religion but to
retire into an echo chamber after not
being able to answer certain
questions about your religion is not
something that promotes
you know intellectual growth
and it's not something that's going to
help you get closer to the truth if
anything is going to push you farther
away because if you can't deal with it
it's most likely because um
you know there is no logical answer to
it
sorry guys
i just want to say also
if you want to discuss it offline we can
have a conversation offline we're not
trying to get views off this
um you know we just we want the truth to
stand out and inshallah today it will
all right so
i'm just pulling it up it's completely
shifted my attitude
guys
i'm gonna say this again right we are
not
enticing any type of threats
harassment physical harm anything like
that so listen
when you watch these videos you you will
get heated there is no doubt you're
gonna get heated you're gonna feel some
type of way just like us
but don't use your emotions and let them
control you and then go sending him
threats or anything like that listen
this is just an academic refutation he's
going to spew nonsense so we got to
check him now
100
by the way guys this is our first time
streaming
so please bear with us like any
technical difficulties anything you see
brother rami is doing his best make dua
for him may allah bless him and
allow this to be a learning curve and us
to master this inshallah
i think this is the best way for me to
uh to do it here
and then make this full screen
and here we
go towards islam before i just thought
this is a false religion now i'm like oh
no this is a tool of satan this is a
tool of satan and the people sorry you
said you can't hear it
yeah i can't hear
all right
triathlon's working overtime to give us
technical difficulties
okay
i'll i'll do it uh
do it like this one second
at least at least that's how you guys
know it's live it's like 12 20 we're
like
you know 20 minutes past
but inshallah it'll be fixed right now
all right
were you guys able
i guess there wasn't a video playing the
first time i share my screen
um no
come on let me let me try one more time
spin though
we're
following it are unknowingly
the soldiers of the dead no
it's a shame it's not funny what he's
saying right now
all right all right let's just tell us
what he said and start
so uh first thing he said is uh muslims
are no no bro you're not gonna play it
i'm gonna figure it out but while i'm
figuring it out we'll just get started
on the points that he's making so the
first thing he says in the clip is that
uh muslims are unknowingly foot soldiers
of the devil
that's funny
that's a funny thing because you know if
you look at islam
the amount of refutation we have for the
devil in islamic text
is far outnumbered
uh or far far outnumbers any of the
religious texts i mean if you look at
for example the jewish text or if you
look at the christian text new testament
old testament
look at us every time we even begin the
recitation of the quran we begin with
a shaytan
right every time we begin to pray we
begin with
we seek refuge with allah from the
cursed and in devil and every time we
look at anything was any temptation we
say
the amount of
any refutations we have against the
devil in islamic text you won't find
anywhere else you know so
that was funny when you hear comments
like that you're like where would you
get that from you know
alhamdulillah in islam we give dawah we
call towards the truth and the truth of
the worship of the one creator
none but one we don't worship the devil
we don't worship prophets we don't
worship saints we worship none but allah
how can that ever be working for the
devil when you're
working against the
the core of what the devil wants you to
do you know so
that's always a weird statement people
make and you're like how did you think
that through you know
yo rami ramirez
um i got a i got a message yeah you see
i got a message saying that they could
have heard it and then i played it back
on youtube and they could hear it only
when me and you and chef couldn't hear
it apparently they could hear it so it's
fine okay someone said share the actual
chrome not the whole screen so let me
try that devil
of the highest degree right he's strong
some of his strongest foot soldiers and
could you hear or no
i couldn't
couldn't damn
that's tough apparently but maybe the
people can yeah i think
the people will be able to want to pull
it on the the screen um
the only thing is i think it's a bug
people are saying share share window not
an odd screen but i mean i just tried
both yeah yeah everyone's saying they
can hear it bro just do it then yeah i
know that people can it's just you guys
that can unfortunately do it i'll i'll
i'll tell you what happens anyway
all right
it's completely shifted my attitude
towards islam before i just thought this
is a false religion now i'm like oh no
this is a tool of satan this is a tool
of satan and the people who are
following it are unknowingly
soldiers of the devil
of the highest degree right his strong
some of his strongest foot soldiers and
so
it completely changed the attitude and
energy i would have going forward to any
time i'm discussing i would look at them
as like oh no you are you're possessed
by a demon there's no no i'm not going
i'm still going to try and portray the
christian values right mercy forgiveness
love you know but i'm not going to
give it the same kind of room and and
courtesies that i would have given to
let's say a christian that i'm
disagreeing with on a particular thing
you know
and so yeah man that that really has
like and it really hardened my heart
towards muslims i have strong negative
feelings
against islam i see it now as like oh
god made a religion it's christianity
the devil made a religion it's called
islam
that's how i see it now
and um i feel bad for anybody who you
know just doesn't know any better
between the true religion
all right i don't know if you guys were
able to hear any of that
he said the muslims that are following
you are unknowingly soldiers of the
devil and some of
satan's biggest highest foot soldiers
are muslims
stuck for allah
it's talking
okay
that's just childish i mean i don't know
you know love to get them on here see
what that means because if you look at
distortion of religious texts this is
the work of christians like if you look
at the discursion of christian practices
for example if you look at christmas
like where did you get christmas from
this was a satanic
uh pagan ritual and and you know
saturnalia the worship of a pagan uh god
and they brought it into christianity
today young dawn included they celebrate
christmas they give out gift they have
christmas trees they have
santa claus coming down chimneys nothing
to do with a7 imagine according to the
majority of biblical scholars jesus was
born in the summer so you know 25th of
december is clearly
not in christianity if you look at
halloween practice a lot of christians
celebrate halloween satanic roots if you
look at all these other practices that
we see today from birthdays onwards you
find that they all have pagan roots and
there's something that muslims don't
celebrate but we see christians
celebrating um
what the bunny and easter all this stuff
is all innovation so
so really if you talk about the devilish
changing of the true message then i'm
not sure how you can even talk about
muslims alhamdulillah as muslims we
stick to the quran we stick to the
authentic hadith of the authentically
established things and actions the
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him and we stick to the true
message we still worship the way out of
the prophet
showed us to worship so
yeah i don't know
and when i mean when you look at
christianity like uh let's look what
predates christians let's look at
judaism let's look at you know the torah
what was satan's mission satan's mission
was to get them to worship other than
god himself
that's why when they crossed the red sea
and god saved them from pharaoh and
pharaoh they made the golden calf and
they worshipped it obviously they were
rebuked for that in the quran at least
moses was very mad at them for that when
he got back and saw that
so if you look at satan's mission from
the old testament his goal is to get you
to worship other than god when you get
to christianity you see
jesus who worshiped god who obeyed the
mosaic law
and after he passes away
300 years later by the way comes the
indoctrination of the trinity that we
have today co-equal eternal persons
within the trinity jesus fully god flame
and all that stuff and they end up
worshiping a man so would you say that
jesus
or sorry would you say that satan
failed in his mission to get people to
worship other than god when you guys are
now worshiping not just
the the father which we would say is god
no problem but the son a man and the
holy spirit as well which we would say
is the angel gabriel and now you see
that islam came with the same message
that jesus originally had which we could
talk about later which religion is more
in line and which religion is farther
from what
god has sent previously
look at the ten commandments first first
commandment is hear o israel your lord
is one not three
second commandment don't worship graven
idols and you look at any church you go
into and you see idols you see statues
of jesus catholics you'll see statues of
everything else from saints to mary to
everybody else
so
for sure the devil's deception is there
in christianity today and like i said i
mean even if you look at the day-to-day
practices celebrations
christmas
no that's from the bible itself there's
none of that is from god none of that is
from revelation that's all innovations
based on devilish descent
you know things that came from paganism
but
100 100
and uh these are the tough questions don
that you have to address you know you
said you don't have to defend the bible
you're acting as if you don't have to
defend your beliefs and you're allowed
to presuppose them that's not true if i
were to claim anything in the world no
matter what it is you would want me to
substantiate it for you especially like
if i came to you and said oh we have
salvation in islam you would ask me and
you did ask to substantiate that on the
life and by the way when sheikh man did
you took your headphones off so you
couldn't even hear and you got back and
you got mad about the fact that it
wasn't answered habibi you took your
headphones off but you have to
substantiate your claims and you have to
defend
your beliefs
shall we move on to the next clip
let's go yeah i'm ready bro
christianity and islam which is of the
devil
and you can see it in the behaviors
after the fact if i went on that stream
and i had talked with all those muslims
and you know and i didn't know anything
about islam i didn't know that the
prophet muhammad the person who invented
a religion right nine year old girl
this is a fact he married a girl at six
years old and then consummated the
marriage at nine that is rape anybody
that wants to try and tell me that a
nine-year-old girl can have consensual
sex with a 53 year old man you're sick
or just so deluded and the reason why it
doesn't phase the average muslim when
you bring that up to them is because
jesus is not in their heart it's because
the holy spirit god is not in their
heart to strengthen that morale how do
you hear this
and try to look past it or rationalize
that the man the quran see i learned a
lot about islam after the fact you know
what i mean what what after the call
after the call yeah because i went into
it looking thinking that i was about to
learn about islam but in them you know
coming for me i had to now go and learn
about it on my own terms eat deceivers
right there he has like
okay so
firstly nobody
yeah yo can i reiterate that so chef
knows what we're even talking about yeah
but before before before we get there
somebody in the chat said that when i
share my screen you guys should click on
the the window that i'm sharing so do
you want to try that quickly just to see
if you can hear
sure i don't mind i tried it before
all right let me tell you one more time
okay oh no but no man you're sick
there's no sound or they're just so
deluded
okay no worries all right all right
just summarize it
he said that
the first thing that i found troublesome
that i want us to address he said that
the person that invented the religion so
he called the prophet sallam the
inventor of islam this is something i
found noteworthy and interesting we can
address this
he said i didn't know that the person
who invented the religion
married and then raped a nine-year-old
right
um that's again we can talk about that
um
he said most of if i remember the third
last point he said most of the people
that are following it aren't fazed by it
because they don't have jesus spirit
within them something like that yeah so
these three we can oh yeah
gotcha first thing alhamdulillah
islam was not started by the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and that's why it's something unique
because if you look at christianity the
word christian is named after what
christ got christ so before jesus who's
called christ
there's no such thing as christianity
you can't have it because it's named
after christ judaism after judah
buddhism after buddha confucianism after
confucius those are differences between
religions and ideologies and all that
but those are all based after somebody
by name alhamdulillah islam is unique in
that that it's not named we're not
muhammad
we are muslim we are those that submit
our will to our creator and that means
islam has been the religion since the
time of adam alaihissalam to islam of
adam till the day of judgment so this is
not something that was started or
invented or began with the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
all of the prophets they submitted their
will they prayed they worshiped as we
find in the old testament in the new
testament to that one great creator so
we believe that all of them were muslim
we believe jesus was a muslim we believe
that abraham was a muslim moses was a
muslim why because the definition of the
word muslim is from the word aslam the
one who submits their will
so
that's the first thing that we need to
correct secondly when you talk about
rape i don't know where the idea of rape
came from but let's talk about marriage
and let's talk about the age of
and i have a standalone video on this as
well if people want to watch they can
watch for more details
regarding the
it's the one message foundation one has
a channel there's links in the
description
and you know it was a part of the sita
the life of the prophet peace be upon
him and we gave a lot of references in
that as well but i'm going to give a
little bit and then i'm going to get
into judeo-christian traditions about
the age of marriage and and young don if
you see this somebody clips and send
this to you i hope you're going to be
fair and honest and open enough that
when i give the references from the
bible you're going to go and look them
up and if you're going to make any kind
of accusations against islam and the
prophet of islam the prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him then i
hope that you will make the same exact
words against other traditions when i
bring them up otherwise your sincerity
will be
will be will be known to everybody
now the age of
that when we talk about this we know the
first thing that we'll have to discuss
that is not a critical issue right and
this is for muslims to understand as
well this is not about
this is not about our belief system
right
because earlier when i talked about the
differences in ages in the bible young
don and others were like well that
doesn't have anything to do with the
belief right it's funny that now they
bring something like this up which is
not a critical issue whether ayashira
dianha was whatever age she may have
been it does not affect the islamic
belief
secondly it is not mentioned in the
quran there is no ayah in the quran that
discusses the age of
when she was married
thirdly it is not mentioned by the
prophet
and what we call
hadith hadith that the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him tells us something
that these are both from revelation from
wahi quran and what the prophet sallam
brought in the sunnah
but the prophet muhammad sallallahu
never discussed the age of
time of her marriage
we do have what we call
literally meaning stopped and moku the
type of hadith where a sahabi a
companion makes a statement not in the
quran it's not only the son of the
prophet
it is not something the prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him told us
i'm not
doubting anything in al-bukhari
some people misunderstood a lot of my
statements because their brains don't
work i guess
i i'm not denying the hadith at all
right
that she was withdrawal or given in
marriage at the age of six and married
at nine
and there's a hadith in sahih muslim
where she mentions she was betrothed at
the age of seven and married at nine and
then we have other weaker narrations
from the historians discussing her death
date and the reports from her sister
asma that put her at different ages
putting that together this is not
rewriting hadith or rewriting the the
the narrative
early scholars like imam and nabali in
his
muslim he discusses the difference
between the numbers meaning whether she
was six or seven at the time of
engagement and he discusses
possibilities why different numbers were
given so again it's not like me sitting
here and today trying to rewrite this to
please somebody no
muslim historians have had a discussion
about this age
and i want also everybody to understand
this doesn't affect
we don't take rulings from this rather
if you look at books like
the age of marriage has to do with
physical and mental maturity and
different people reach that at different
times and different signs even below
understanding whether it's having to do
with the period or aid
there's discussions about when somebody
can get married and the essence of that
in fact is that when they're physically
and and apart from that mentally ready
for marriage
so
having said all this because i'm making
this clear because when i give
references later they might be like oh
this is it in the bible or this
understand this is not something in the
quran and this is not something the
prophet
told us about
when she gives her about her age and i
have no doubt that she made those
statements i don't doubt her precision
she's an excellent narrator of hadith or
those books of hadith but the fact that
in two sahih hadith one in muslim and
one in bukhari she gives two different
ages
shows that this is not something that
was accurately known at the time not
that her reporting is not accurate her
reporting is excellent but none of us
are
mentally present at the time of birth
none of us notice hey you're born and
like hey i'm born today what's the time
what's the date right
if we ask anyone here when you were born
you're going to look at a birth
certificate you're going to look at your
passport you're going to go ask your mom
you don't remember right so you're
basically taking information from other
sources and if those sources have some
ambiguity then you're going to pass that
on arabs had no calendar understand this
that the arabs had no calendar i don't
mean that they didn't have a lunar
assault they had no calendar basically
they would have events like amil seal
the year when abraham attacked makkah
the elephant and they would kind of give
it a name from an event or a drought or
a flood or a lot of rain and they would
give it a name and they would try to
map ages from that and that's why not
just discussing
even khatija
the first wife of the prophet
who by the way as long as he was married
to he didn't marry any other woman
she passed away and then he married the
woman after that but until she was alive
she was his only wife
even her age is disputed i mean there
are reports from laura walcott that
mentioned that she was 40 at the time of
her marriage and we know walker these
weakened narrations so the uh
in vidal
we mentioned that if nikola says that he
will choose closer to 25 to 28. why
because again the audibles were not
concerned about recording your birthday
most of the early scholars also we know
their death dates we don't know their
birthday for the early scholars of islam
and the sahaba and so on some of them we
have ideas because if they have major
uh events that happened that year like
the year of the field ahmed field of the
elephant with the year the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
was born and because of that major event
we know but if people were born in years
where they weren't major events then
it's very hard to know their exact age
what we can say about
that her age was appropriate for the
time for marriage and how do we know
that that she was already engaged to
jubair and bin mutterim before she was
even engaged i'm not talking about
marriage talking about engagement to the
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
for us to judge that age today
is what's called presentism this is this
is not fair it's not uh appropriate why
um rami if you can on your screen
bring up uh safari google chrome i don't
really care look up average life expense
expectancy 6th century
yeah
and for anyone that didn't hear that
that's the logical fallacy of presentism
okay 30 to 35.
if you can share the screen inshallah
forever
we'll give them that visual yeah
everyone everyone can like accept
youtube you guys are the odd ones though
okay good tell us and if everybody can
see it it's good so what is the average
life expectancy 30 to 35 years old
30 to 35 years old
think about that this is the sixth
century this is when the prophet isaiah
was born this is the time we're looking
at
in that time period your average life
expenses it was 30-35 today it's about
77 years of age in hong kong in japan
it's around 80.
okay
so today when we talk about the age of
marriage being 18 that would not be
practical for that time
today when we talk about oh
he's too young to get married she's too
young to get married what do we talk
about they haven't finished their
schooling
right she didn't finish high school she
didn't finish college he didn't get a
degree yet
understand in those times you don't have
any of that so when a girl was
physically mature when when the
biological indicators were there for
example she got her period or you know
other signs that show maturity they
would get married because nature would
tell them you are now physically ready
to get married and that was very common
they didn't have school to go to they
didn't have med school they didn't have
any of this they didn't you know this is
what they did men at the time when they
were physically capable would go out and
work they would do trade they would go
plant seeds uh you know they would farm
today if we take a 12 year old and put
them to work people say this is uh child
labor laws you know this is abusing
children and
you're taking advantage of the child
because he should finish his schooling
but that would mean the whole world was
abusing children at the time because
everybody when they were physically old
enough 12 13 14 years of age they would
go out and work right so this is a this
is a fallacy this is this something that
is not correct and anybody with a bit of
logic would understand this right
at that time this was that regular way
or age to get married
but
if we have uh mr young
don
talking about pedophilia i'm going to
bring up something from his bible and i
know he feels he doesn't need to defend
his bible but he needs to at least
defend his statements now right
um if you don't mind rami can you bring
up the first screenshot that i sent you
100
excellent so
i'm going to give you guys some bible
verses and i'm going to leave the
screenshot there and i want to discuss
it in a minute
but i want everybody to write down these
verses as well so they can keep this as
a record
if we look in the bible the bible that
mr don claims to believe in that he's
promoting that christians
hand out to us that give out that you go
to hotels and you find it in their
drawers uh in genesis 17 17 we find and
if one of you guys can take some notes
here as well
that sarah was 90 when abraham was 100
ibrahim alayhi salam
right
she was 90
when ibrahim abraham was 100 according
to genesis 17 17.
you got me
okay
now
so i have i have three links
i have the um
just
just the first link just leave it there
um it's a commentary and we're not gonna
i'm gonna get to that in a minute okay
but first i just want you guys to write
these ages or remember them okay
genesis 17 17 in the bible again i want
to make a point the age of
not in the quran the prophet didn't tell
us we do know from
hadith and think we have no problem with
that
but this i'm giving you from the bible
itself
from their text their holy text okay
sarah was 90 abraham was 100 genesis 17
17.
in genesis 21 5
abraham was 100 when ishaq or isaac was
born
okay
in genesis 23 1 and 2 in the beginning
we find that sarah died at the age of
127.
stay with me you can watch this
recording again later if you want to
really get this down
isaac is hawk was 40 when he married
rebecca according to the bible look of
genesis 25 20.
explicit he was 40 years old when he
married rebecca
sarah was 90 when isaac was born
according to the bible when isaac was
born sarah was 90 years old
that's a conclusion you can take from
one and two from sarah being 90 when
abraham was 100 and abram being 100 when
isaac was born so she was
here now is fine that she was 90 when
isaac was born
now
isaac or his hawk was 37 when his mother
sarah died
okay look at that if you take 127
subtract 90 from it you get 37.
and it's hard being 37 at his mother's
death
and he was 37 when rebecca was born
because rebecca was born when sarah died
so isaac was 40 according to this when
he married rebecca who was three years
old
so one more time 40 year old married
rebecca at three years old
and again according because i'm a muslim
because i'm a muslim they might be like
oh you're trying to misread our text and
that's why rami has now brought up a
screenshot
and this one i'm going to discuss this
is a you have the
aramaic or the hebrew text right there
this is a commentary on the old
testament or the torah by rabbi basha
ibn ashir
and this here if you look at the
scroll down you will find that he
clearly saves and this is a jewish
classic accepted commentary uh very
early on
um this is not something you know we've
come up with recently uh this was i
think written uh the rabbi
uh review was uh i think around
12 55 to 1340. this is any a few hundred
years old classic well and this website
is a jewish website it's not a muslim
website
so what does he say based on biblical
text he says and it's very clear it says
the torah itself testifies that it suck
i
mean
was 40 years old when he married
ripka which is rebecca who which
makes rebecca three years old when she
was married
you can you highlight that on your
screen so people can see yeah actually
it's been highlighted for the last like
two minutes three minutes maybe except
is there no way for you to put us on the
bottom of that screenshot while you're
screen sharing
that's okay i don't think so as long as
everybody else can see it okay so now we
want to be very very explicit here that
these rabbis biblical scholars in
accepted well-known biblical
commentaries that are right now on
jewish websites and we're talking about
the old testament which again as
christians supposed to believe in when
they give us the bible it's not just the
new testament they have the old
testament there they believe that this
is the same god that they worship jesus
was the same god of the old testament so
that means according to their bible
isaac
40 year old married a three-year-old and
this is the works of their god and this
is not just
a biblical incident i'm going to now
take you to the second
uh
link that i sent to you rami if you can
bring that up
okay
and it's loading in okay so we got
genesis 25 22.
excellent so now this is from the old
testament part of the bible and it
clearly mentions here
um if we go down
that
isaac was
40. and
bring it up here
here
genesis 25 20 isaac was 40 years old
when he took white rebecca
uh now if you look on the right hand
side you will find the commentary from
rashi rashi
is a
standard well-known commentary used for
biblical
references it was
written by rabbi solomon even isaac and
he is 10 40 to 1106 very classic it's
commonly known as rashi
and this is as you can read in the
introduction this is the single most
influential jewish biblical commentary
of the middle ages
anybody who studied judaism anybody
who's christians that have studied the
old testament know that this is a
standard this is the well-known accepted
commentary from the middle ages what
does rashi say he says when abraham came
from mount moriah he received the news
rebecca was born and he gives the
reference 22 20. isaac was 37 years old
because at that time sarah died from the
birth of isaac until the binding when
sarah died there was 37 years since she
was 90 years old when isaac was born and
127 years old when she died
as it is said in 2031 he's giving all
the biblical references here and the
life of sarah was 127 years
thus isaac was then 37 years old at the
period rebecca was born and he waited
until she was now pay attention to this
until she was fit for marriage which was
three years
and then married her
according to the bible the age that a
girl is fit for marriage is three years
of age and this is not a muslim
commentary this is not me trying to
interpret their texts this is their own
scholars in their own commentaries using
their own bible
okay
now two years old
three years old is the age for marriage
right according to them not us not as
muslims right if you want to talk about
pedophilia let's talk about pedophilia
right but we'll get to it we'll get to
the new testament too relax all the
christians that are jumping up and down
you guys claim you believe in the old
testament it's part of the bible that
you give you claim it's the same god so
you believe in this okay
now if you can go to the third link i
sent you
all right
third link
yes
all right it's looking like
uh
541 doctor joshua culp
yo rami yeah one one question yeah are
you able to increase the the audio from
me and you because i got a couple of
messages from people saying that me and
you are really quiet but sheikh is clear
which is all that matters honestly at
the end of the day but yeah
but still
i want to feel some of those audio like
you know
so
here uh while you guys play the audio
this is the talmud
this is the commentaries of the jewish
rabbis that based their rulings off of
the bible of the old testament right of
the of the torah
and here
in the explanation of it it mentions
in the talmud itself
this is jewish law a girl of the age of
three years and one day if you're more
than three years if you're a day more
maybe be thought by intercourse if
jalam had intercourse with her he
acquires her thereby this is
old testament law okay what does that
mean that if a girl is one day more than
three years of age and somebody has sex
whether it's forcefully or not
he is now her husband she will be
betrayed to him as it is as stated above
intercourse with a girl over the age of
three years counts as intercourse
therefore since withdrawal may be
performed by intercourse she may be
betrayed in this way if she is
liable for jabon meaning a previous
husband which i don't know how a
three-year-old could have a previous
husband but and the yolam her dead
husband's brother had intercourse with
her she becomes his wife
at three years of age
read this this again look at the website
that's why i shared the link i'm not
just reading it so people can go look it
up this is not us as muslims coming in
so if you want to take shots don come
let's talk about it right let's bring up
your bible right we'll get to it
now
again
this means intercourse he creates legal
obligation legal relationship
and
who is liable for adultery with her it
says her father who marries her off to
someone else
understanding that according to jewish
law a girl
who is a katana this is a kitana this is
a word that's used in their law
according to the old testament
at between the age of 3 and 12
can be given in marriage even without
her consent by her father
right because it's the legal age of
marriage between 3 and 12
according to the old testament laws
right
now i know we're going to get some fun
uh
christians that are going to say oh you
know this the old testament or new
testament
okay
first thing as i've clearly mentioned
repeatedly now um
the bible that you guys give out as
christians contains the old testament
you do believe in it supposedly right so
this is all applicable to you but let's
talk about jesus and mary and joseph
the earliest document that i could find
that discusses the age of joseph i'm not
talking about people today trying to
rewrite history the earliest that i can
find it's from the sixth and seventh
centuries which is a book called the
history of joseph the carpenter um and
here uh robin gay mottamir banette
probably mispronouncing that european um
says in the book in the history of
joseph the carpenter that
if you look at early church fathers and
their writing early evangelical church
that they believe that joseph was 90
years of age look up the book yourself
look again don
if you watch this or any other christian
go get the book you can get on amazon
the history of joseph the carpenter look
it up yourself right what do they say
they say that joseph was 90 years of age
and mary was 12.
how old was she
12.
so now catholics you call saint joseph
christians you call him a great
personality in the biblical structure
the stepfather of god according to you
guys right uh you know one of the first
believers that he defended mary all of
us right you're going to call him
pedophile
let's
let's see let's you live by what you say
because if a 90 year old marries a 12
year old today that's what you would
call them
but right now you can make oh no no no
this is this is not in the bible itself
well the age of
the united
going to use your historic st
that tell us that joseph was 90 marrying
a 12 year old now
i'm going to mention something just for
dawn a little fun thing because he
mentioned an author during our stream
what was the author do you guys remember
john mccarthy macarthur right john
mccarthy
john mcarthur was the one that don
brought up
right not me not you he brought it home
well i have a lot of his books i have
his biblical commentary i also have a
book it's called god in the manager
and the miraculous birth of christ
in which
john macarthur
the one that don brought up says that
that mary was likely engaged to joseph
when she was between 12 and 13 years of
age
so
there is no getting out of this don
your own john mcarthur says he was 12
years old 12-13 right the earliest
scriptures that you have the catholic
encyclopedia i don't care if you're not
catholic just because i've given
christian references protestant
references i'm gonna give catholic
references they also mention that
that according to them uh joseph when he
was 40 he had married another woman and
i'm going to read from this um this is
before his marriage to mary when he was
40 years of age joseph married a woman
called milcha or
esther by some
by others
then lived 49 years together and had six
children two daughters and four sons the
youngest of them was james which is
mentioned in the bible james
the less the lord's brother they say
a year after his wife's death as the
priests announced through judea that
this they wished to find in the tribe of
judah a respectable man to spouse mary
then 12 to 14 again 12 to 14 years of
age at the time
years of age and joseph was 90 years old
this is not just one reference it's not
just christians it's not just catholics
it's the earliest references and the
current and john mcarthur himself gives
her age at 12. here again she's 12 and
he's how old
90 years old when he went up to
jerusalem amongst the candidates and a
miracle manifested in the choice of god
had made joseph and the truth is god's
will that he was doing and two years
later uh anyway so now
just to give you a couple of references
there's not like some you know
obscure reference that i found bernard
fontana he also mentioned that mary was
12 and joseph was 90. these are the
well-respected christian authors and
scholars that they put out there um in
charles talbert's commentary on the new
testament this is a new testament on
matthew he also says that did mary have
sexual relations with joseph but they
remember like oh joseph doesn't have
relations with her he clearly says he
goes mary had sexual relations because
in the bible in matthew it states that
mary did not have sexual relations with
joseph until after jesus birth
so he says from amongst the early
witnesses we find that mary did have a
sexual relationship with joseph after
the birth of jesus according to
christian scholars
um tony coffey he says that matthew had
stated that joseph had no sexual
relationship very until she gave birth
to a son
this tells us that after jesus birth
joseph
who was past 90 at this time and mary
who was around 13 past 12 years of age
had normal sexual relations like any
other couple tony coffee right
so
what does that tell us
if don and any other christian is going
to be sincere and honest and be straight
up about it then i want them to go in
and tell us why joseph was a battle why
uh isaac was a pedophile why all these
biblical references
tell tell them and when they come back
and say oh no no no at that time when
mary was withdrawal that was the average
age when people got married then the
same is true for ayesha
right
in fact the age gap between joseph and
marriage is much more than that of
between the prophet muhammad sallallahu
salaam
and the age gap between isaac and
rebecca in the bible is also much more
than that which is between the prophet
muhammad
so
we come at it straight there's no
ambiguity here we're coming out with
evidences with biblical verses with
books and references and if they're
honest sincere even right now if they
jump on i'm here i'm ready to take a
face-to-face conversation with anybody
who wants to do it
so shea just to quickly interject a lot
of people are commenting this what's the
age of majority in islam and from all i
know the age of majority is
that you are mature that's it the age of
maturity not majority age of maturity is
that you are mature now correct me if
i'm wrong so
in islam we discussed this issue of bulu
of who becomes balik and there are many
different sides with signs between a man
and a woman that shows when they are
physically mature um one of them is for
a woman for example if she gets her head
if she gets her period
for a man and then a certain hair that
grows in certain places certain dreams
certain things that we look at to know
whether they're bali but that also
doesn't mean that they're ready for
marriage
because as the kuttub of the first books
that marriage is done when somebody is
physically capable and able for marriage
and
many of the commentaries then also talk
about a mental state right
so what does that mean um a girl may be
at a age where her period doesn't come
because in her culture her environment
the period comes very late or some that
come very early but she may not be
physically ready for marriage so at that
time we would not allow that to be an
islamic marriage islam looks at what we
call our means the local customs and
traditions look at merge age right
meaning that if
for example in a country where there is
no education system there's no schooling
um the average life like expectancies
are very low and people get married
early as long as the woman is physically
ready naturals indicators of marriage
and the man is physically ready then
they could get married in other cultures
if there is a delayed period meaning the
people are going to school they have
things and they want to wait till
they're older nothing wrong with that we
look at the earth there we don't allow
marriage until somebody has the natural
indicators of marriage we don't give a
age because if we said 10
not every 10 year old is the same
everywhere else right in america for
example the legal age for marriage and
many states used to be 10 years of age
and now they've bumped it up to 16 and
some states 18 but most states still at
around 16. some are still i think at 14
you can look it up
why because time and locations differ
till today in africa there are countries
where the life spans are very low
education is not exist in and women
regularly get married at 10 and 12 years
of age and we sitting in america to say
that's wrong is very
you know hypocritical of us because even
in america that used to be the fact
and i'll say one more thing one of the
hypocrisies of western society is when
they talk about child marriages they
don't talk about sex of under eight
children
we have middle school kids that are
pregnant right
i went to a school that had a daycare i
mean and this was my middle school in
san diego um because so many girls had
already especially if you look at the
latina community so many girls had
already had children right
i ha i have people that i went to school
with that at 12 and 13 got pregnant
meaning they were already having sex
before that so somebody is old enough to
be having sex why aren't dull enough to
get married you know this is something
that we find as a hypocrisy in western
society because at age 18 for example
where did we come up with that number
you know some people at 18 may not
physically be ready for marriage some
people at 18 maybe some people at 16 may
be ready you know so in islam we don't
go by just putting a arbitrary number we
look at first and foremost the natural
indicators of the body if a woman has
her period if a man has
certain natural indicators that won't
get into detail here but in our fifth we
discuss it
then we say that they are naturally
the nature of the person shows that they
are ready for sexual intercourse and
ready for marriage that doesn't mean
they should get married at that age they
may not be mentally prepared they don't
have to islam doesn't say it right when
that happens get married no
but if they are mentally
mature and in the earth and the
tradition of their land they can and
they should
right so this is the islamic rulings
all right
one thing i want to say is uh you can
turn your mic up on your end most likely
uh secondly i think that's
uh here echo for a second but
my gain is the highest oh i see i see
okay i know where's inshallah alright so
we'll do it afterwards okay
i think that was clear for everyone one
thing i want to add is um just a little
note uh i want once i heard it never
left my mind in california there is no
minimum age requirement with parental
consent so if aisha was alive today or
anyone nowadays they could legally get
married with parental consent which she
had aisha
in california today
if you have a problem with that
go to the county
file some kind of complaint
talk to your political representative
and throw your tantrums there don maybe
he lives in cali himself i don't know
throw your tantrums there go to the
county and complain
and again i mean even if you look at
age of consent or age of marriage today
that's all arbitrary we're just making
up numbers to be honest right because if
you look at like i said if your life
expense expectancy is between 30 and 35
you can't expect somebody to wait till
they're 20 years old to have their first
child right they won't even be you know
10 15 years old the parents will be dead
right so how do you raise children that
way and if you have no schooling system
what do you do i mean once you're bald
when you're when you're mature when
you're physically natural indicators
show that you're ready for marriage
you're just going to sit around wait 10
years for what you know so so that's
that's the whole point that people are
looking at this all wrong
but again and inshallah i'm going to
jump off and let you guys continue
having your fun but
uh we have a conference i got to get to
here but uh i will again leave with a
couple of summary points one
uh regarding the age of ayahuasca no
doubt that she was at an appropriate age
of marriage for that time period because
none of the mushrikeen the polity is
ever objected to her marriage her
parents didn't object to her marriage
nobody else in that society until the
1900s western
academics didn't object to that marriage
because their own kings and in my video
that i have about the age of
i show western kings and queens that got
married at much younger ages than ayesha
and this was in the 16th century and
17th century not the sixth
right so uh the hypocrisy of dawn and
others in the west it it's mind-blowing
right
secondly
if you're gonna throw some kind of
statements out there then i want you to
go back and look at the bible and i want
you to look at the reference that i gave
and i want you to look at those
commentaries and i want you to look at
those reference with the age of joseph
in the age of mary and then i want you
to use the same standard be fair and
balanced and use the same standard in
what you're talking about
and lastly
i want to go back to this that none of
this has to do with credible issues
none of this has to do with arteda this
is just somebody who was on a live
stream got caught and showing that the
bible shows that jesus didn't know the
hour he didn't know knowledge that the
father knew so now he can't be co-equal
because he doesn't know and your creedal
issues fall apart the death of judas
falls apart the the clear contradictions
in the bible show that what you're
basing your salvation on is a book that
has been flawed has been changed and
edited and has clear numeric
contradictions your own author that you
mentioned john macarthur says that there
are copies of errors in the bible and
now that your
base of your creed and your belief and
your book fell apart you're looking for
excuses to take shots
i want you to go back to creedal issues
and go back to understanding and use a
fair and balanced way and if you want to
jump on with us another time inshallah
i'll be more than willing to come back
and have a conversation directly uh with
don or anybody else inshallah
inshallah
all right so you guys
heard it here saw it here first very
clear
very like it's it's kata bro it's clear
cut there is no way out dawn all you can
do now is be fair say that you are on an
emotional high
and apologize for your blatant
statements or make the same statements
about christianity and at the end of the
day
know that you actually have achieved
nothing
for christianity you have achieved
nothing for christianity and actually
even nothing against islam
i want to take this time to talk about
some of the super chats i apologize for
taking so long i took pictures of them
so i can uh
get to them uh so i'm going to go in
reverse order
uh think before you type he sent to
actually first he says or secondly he
says exactly
of
america age of consent was literally as
young as seven years old and most states
was 10 up until 1920.
by the way yo daniel kiko is ready
oh yeah okay just give me give me a
second two seconds
um
and on why mouse says numbers 31 18 has
a baby and child has baby and child
marriages concubines of girls whose
parent whose parents and baby brothers
wiped out by the israelites supposedly
by musa
by moses
subhanallah
uh someone asked sheikh regarding her
mother ashley there's a lot of evidence
to support that she was actually 17 to
19. can you comment on that
i'm not the sheikh all i will say is
that
the evidences don't fully wholly add up
i know sheikh has a different opinion on
it he doesn't believe that she was or
wasn't i'm not going to speak on his
behalf but as far as i know he doesn't
believe that she was or wasn't 17 to 19
or whatever he does have a video on it
on his one message foundation where he
talks about the age of aisha he goes
into the evidences and talks about it
and you can go watch that insha allah on
your own time akram
says
dear sheikh regarding her mother aisha
oh i already read that um i think before
you type
he sent the same message twice may allah
bless you bro so you have to read it
twice there was a sister sarah that
donated may allah bless you and brother
ali chabar was the first one to donate
two hundred dollars may allah bless you
mostly uh with thank you for the kind
message as well so proud of you guys for
the good work may allah bless you happy
all right that's out of the way let me
invite
to the chat actually can you invite him
are you friends with him
i'm not unfortunately bro okay it's okay
let me um i don't want to read his
username because then random people are
gonna decide that's okay i just put
short break
for a second let me just
invite him into the chat
and by the way guys thank you all for
the messages um helping us
kind of get everything set up here you
know giving me advice to do this do that
fix this fix that
uh insha allah i definitely will
after the
stream just gotta get through this first
inshaallah i think this is definitely
good enough for now
and uh we have with us here brother
daniel
you're looking good
i think he's sorting out some audio
things
guys you gotcha and all right in the
meantime five bro how are you feeling
man what are your thoughts i'm the love
bro could you hear me
i can't hear you guys oh there you can't
hear us we can hear you though
you hear me know
can you hear me hear me can you hear me
now yeah
first time using this
ramy can you hear me yeah i can hear you
now
okay okay
i don't know what's going on man the
audio interface just picks it up and
then loses it so you might need to
honestly return it and get another one
maybe the focus is better
but um what we'll do with it we'll do
with inshallah i think i think
everything's good now the stream is a
lot smoother
um
we have two more clips that actually
maybe it's not best that we play them
because you guys actually can't hear
um but we do have what do you mean they
could hear it
no you guys can't hear it they can hear
it but you guys can't oh well daniel
already saw it so you can still play it
okay all right type so let me play the
rest of the clip
now in the meantime
yeah
yeah
is the voice quality okay yeah it's good
can you hear us
yeah i can hear you all right so we're
gonna have to level up oh my god oh my
god
how are you doing man
you too
type so we have uh sonam family said
daniel in the house and donated two
dollars
uh and someone else said that the
marissa aisha was through revelation
wahi if i recall correctly also one who
ordained it whatever allah ordains is
pure 100 and that's the thing about
morality uh you can't
definitively say anything unless you're
you have revelation from god that's the
only time you can wholesomely say this
is objectively true
so when you're dealing with religion it
makes no sense to make a moral argument
unless you can prove your religion to
begin with and this is the problem i
think a lot of christians have they
presuppose their religion and assume
that we have to as well but no they have
to justify it and maybe we could talk a
little bit more about that so
brother daniel i know you saw the video
i think what i'm going to do is play the
rest of it there's a few minutes for the
stream and then we'll get back and we'll
talk about some of the points
all right miss mila so
this guy titled it young
and the reason why it doesn't phase the
average muslim when you bring that up to
them is because jesus is not in their
heart it's because the holy spirit god
is not in their heart to strengthen that
morale how do you hear this this is and
try to disguise the position or
rationalize that the part of me
this guy is a musician
young don uh i have no idea
but do you know
why is he popular
i i know i know that he used to make
like animations on youtube and that was
his main account and then he made a side
account when he converted to
christianity
and how recently did he convert to
christianity two months as admitted by
himself on the last stream
man so in two months he's like
starting to go to war and he wants to
like antagonize others yeah he wants he
wants to smoke
yeah and at the in the worst way
possible because i mean
this this is a guy that said that he
wanted to learn about islam and i mean
the way he did it is the equivalent of
me having a stomachache and going to the
garbage man for a diagnosis he went to
apos david wood nabil kreshi
all of which have never been muslim
especially in real christian he was in
ahmedi he's still not a muslim and um
tried to learn about islam and when he
came to to learn about christianity from
sheikh man he was very angry afterwards
so i don't see why he would do the same
thing
um
with this now learn from he's a he's a
youtuber bro i don't think he's a
musician he does make music like he does
make songs but his main thing was he's a
youtuber he has about three million subs
his youtuber his youtube name channel
name is young sauce god and he just
makes animated stories
that's what he does he calls himself a
god and
he's so is he christian i don't get it
i think that's the third
yeah but um let me let me play the last
few minutes of the uh of the clip here
the man the the quran see i learned a
lot about islam after the fact you know
what i mean what what after the call
after the call yeah because i went into
it looking thinking that i was about to
learn about islam but in them you know
coming for me i had to now go and learn
about it on my own terms deceivers right
there he has like 99
um
magical names or something like that 99
special names one of them is the great
deceiver right
because that is who satan is saying is
regarded as the greatest of deceivers
you know and
ironically muslims don't see that they
don't see that right a lot of them will
say false right like if they're in the
chat or you know a false fall they say
fall you know why they say false one
they could be lying intentionally
knowing that they are lying because
again it's permissible in islam or two
it is because they haven't read the
quran because
most muslims are uneducated on the quran
i can't even hear that
it is incredible yeah for some reason
discord when i try sharing my screen it
doesn't uh it doesn't play the volume i
can share it and you can like read the
captions but uh we decided just to play
for the audience and then come back and
talk about it so the point that the the
clip that i just played um
is uh extraordinarily funny one in my
opinion uh because he used the uh
god is the great deceiver in the quran
argument after saying god has 99 magical
names like this is some fairy tale
and then
he went on to
to say that most muslims actually don't
know the quran and they intentionally
lie because it's a part of the religion
so you see that he just went to like
islamwiki.com.net or whatever and
wikileaks looked at the most common uh
arguments so
if there's anything you want to talk
about first daniel inshallah we can
definitely jump to those things if not
then why don't you talk about the whole
misconception of allah being the
greatest deceiver versus greatest
planner where the argument comes from
and so on and so forth
so this is a common argument that's used
by
christian apologists
but it's completely nonsensical like you
don't even need to know the bible or
anything about christianity to recognize
that this is a ridiculous
bad faith argument from christians
because allah is deceiving those who are
deceivers themselves those who engage in
deception and those who commit injustice
are the ones that are going to be
deceived
because they're delusional in their
rejection of allah rejection of
god and islam
and they want to create mischief
in the earth they want to trick the
believers and deceive them and they
think that they can trick or deceive
allah their creator
this is their mentality
but
it's
it's very just and very fitting that
this is the tables are turned on them
and in fact they're the ones who are
deceived
so what is what is the problem with this
like what is the moral problem with this
if someone is immoral and if someone
is uh dishonest and someone is
committing all kinds of uh crimes trying
to create bloodshed and mischief in the
land
then it's completely immoral even from
an atheist perspective or christian
perspective or jewish hindu perspective
that that person deserves a taste of his
own medicine
right
so
even on its face like this objection
against islam
is completely dishonest and
in bad faith like they're taking like
the worst most uncharitable reading
of the quran in order to
make this kind of criticism but we can
go further because in the in the bible
itself
there are examples where
god is quoted
as
deceiving as wanting to deceive and lie
to people
like this is explicit in
not only the old testament but also the
new testament
so some references for you in first
kings
chapter 22 verse 20
it starts and the lord said who will
entice ahab
into attacking ramoff gilead and going
to his death there one suggested this
and another that finally a spirit came
forward stood before the lord and said i
will entice him
by what means the lord asked and the
spirit says i will go out and be a lying
spirit in the mouths of all of his
prophets
you will
that's what the spirit said and then god
says you will succeed in enticing him go
and do it
so god is authorizing this spirit to go
lie
in order to entice and to deceive and
trick
so this is one example in first kings
another example in second thessalonians
chapter 2 verse 11 for this reason god
sends them a powerful delusion
so that they will believe the lie
so how much more explicit can you be
about god sending lot
basically god is lying to people
which is not in islam
allah doesn't lie
to humanity deceiving someone in context
of the quran
means that it's their own self-delusion
that allah that god allows them to
continue to be deluded
and
and that's how they get mixed up that's
how they trip over themselves as
evil people but this in these verses
it's like god is just going and sending
lies
according to them according to the bible
in jeremiah chapter 4 verse 10 then i
said ah sovereign lord how completely
you have deceived this people and
jerusalem by saying you will have peace
when the sword is at our throats
so again there was uh
this
peace that was supposed to happen
but according to jeremiah the sovereign
lord lied or deceived people
when there was no peace there was just
war and swords at the throats
so i mean we can go into the commentary
on this and the commentary confirms this
interpretation like all of the
uh traditional christian commentaries
will confirm that yeah sometimes god
according to the bible will deceive
people and outright lie to them
and yeah they'll have like a certain
kind of way to explain why that's okay
but at the end of the day it's deception
it's it's deceiving people it's lying to
people
and it's it's explicit in the bible so
how can you
criticize islam when islam is not in the
quran it's not even at that level
so
that's you know i don't know if you guys
have any thoughts on that i um honestly
i am flabbergasted bro i don't know and
like i'm just thinking about this from
dawn's perspective i'm trying to be
respectful as possible but honestly like
don you're in a bad situation like a
very like every single argument that you
have made has flipped back on you i want
you to understand that every single
argument you've made so far has flipped
back on you we're gonna keep adding to
it not to be spiteful or hateful or
vengeful but to just speak the truth
because that's what muslims are taught
to do so now you have two options
continue in your arrogance and ignorance
and persist in this and achieve
literally nothing and then lose your
credibility as a person as a man or come
back be honest or take take a month to
learn come back be honest and admit
these were flawed arguments you did it
out of emotion and you have no argument
against islam next thing i want to
mention is he was talking about the name
of allah where we say that allah is the
best of planners and there's this common
for some reason common argument that uh
this is translated to the greatest
deceiver
for some reason allahu adam
i'm not sure why but that was the main
argument that i think he was making
and then he makes a very interesting
point it's unrelated because we've dealt
with that it's done and i'm still
flabbergasted by those verses i found a
lot
god
to jerusalem to jerusalem
said they're going to be in a state of
peace and now they're at war with a
sword to their neck this is god's people
come on man
but side note he said that muslims don't
know the quran
he said muslims don't know the quran and
it always needs interpretation that
every time you buy a quran it comes with
all these footnotes because like there
are footnotes at the bottom and so on
and so forth
and he uses this as kind of an argument
against the quran for some reason that
oh you can't just read it for yourself
you wanna you wanna play it or
i already played that part okay yeah
so yeah so i i mean
planning
because makr
um
which is the use like in in certain ayat
that's the
or allah says for example
uh in the third chapter of the quran
verse 54.
mecca rule being past
they plotted
it's not plan is not exactly right
translation for that um because it's
like
is
a kind of deceptiveness like conspiring
they conspired
to do something wrong
and um so this is what i was referring
to allah is saying in this verse in the
quran that they plotted they planned
they tried to deceive
and then allah okay also plotted against
them or not in you know it's
it's not like allah is planning because
allah is all-knowing god is all-knowing
he's all wise he already knows about
their plans he already knows about their
plots but that's like the foolishness of
someone who thinks that he can deceive
and like work against
the work against god's plans
and christians have this a similar
expression like god works in mysterious
ways
right so god what that means is that
things happen you think that things are
going to happen in a certain way in life
and then something else happens that you
didn't expect and god works in
mysterious ways and that's the way that
um
these disbelievers or those who are
trying to fight against allah and his
messengers
those who are trying to deceive the
believers they think that they have the
upper hand they think that they're in
control and that's what gives them the
confidence to scheme and connive and
deceive
and do this kind of makru
but in fact it's allah who's in control
allah is the one who's all-powerful
allah is the one who is going to turn
their plots against them and that's so
purely justified that's purely you know
we can see the superiority of that
and the
beautiful
nature of that that's how allah operates
um and so this is not something that is
foreign to christianity it's not foreign
to judaism in fact according to the
bible uh their understanding of god goes
much further
than just retaliation or um
reciprocity between
um these two like
giving the deceivers and the criminals
they're just desserts
one hundred percent jazakallah because
actually i didn't know that about makara
and the actual definition and often you
do see it translated as um you know they
plan on the law plans and allows the
best of planners so
for being you know completely
transparent and honest about it and i
think honestly that's probably one of
the best explanations of it that i've
heard so
if i do have anything to add before we
move on and play the rest of the clip
um
i'm gonna be honest bro i have something
to add but it's going to be leading into
a side tangent but someone sent me a
screen recording of him in a stream
claiming that hinduism is a monotheistic
religion bro and i don't even want to
get it
as a christian he has to as a christian
he has to because they believe in
brahman as far as i know and then that
one god is broken down to millions of
other gods
and that's why he has to say that uh
it's monotheistic to some degree
man just played play for fourth clip bro
boring and hard to read one and two it
requires wait it is incredible most
muslims are uneducated on the quran that
is just a fact it is incredibly boring
and hard to read he just says
am i can they hear me bro yeah yeah they
can hear you yeah for anyone wondering
where angel is brother angel is
traveling at the moment so inshallah he
will join us next session in sha allah
and everyone jazak for the super chats
may allah bless you all immensely
everyone send this stream to someone
else and write the words oh my god this
is crazy uh to get them to click on it
and i want it to double in sha allah
so viral
inshallah
i want you guys to take and he just said
the quran
is incredibly boring to read that's how
i know he hasn't read the bible because
he would literally eat his words if he
actually read the bible
it's literally
like there's like hundreds of thousands
of words in the bible bro
bro the amount of books you need of
interpretation and
explanations and all this don't even get
me started yeah and it's insane i'm just
gonna play the rest of the clip
the one and two it requires
interpretation it didn't quite like you
can't read the quran on your own
even in quran you go out to buy it will
come with
like notes and interpretation notes if
you just try to read it on your own and
you read it plainly oftentimes they'll
say you're reading it wrong
and that's one of the biggest arguments
that they will have when you try to
bring up errors in the quran for
instance dior
why don't you eat pork
because
the filth
the
what the you know i know i just said a
lot of really harsh things about the
religion the false religion
and i know in islam you are trained to
to
one because you don't have truly have
the holy spirit within you so you don't
really have grace and kindness and mercy
in your heart you feel me
um which is a state that i'm very
familiar with i know what if okay so i'm
not going to play the rest of this clip
all i'm going to say is that he
basically goes on to say that before
christianity he was at a point where he
was so angry at little petty things that
people would do that he would have
thoughts of if i could stamp my fingers
and this person would be dead and i got
away with it clean i would do it um and
he's talking about this kind of state
before christianity and his his boys are
kind of like you know what the hell do
you want bro what the hell are you
talking about i've never felt that and
he asked like he tried to reason with
them oh you never felt that and they're
like no yeah so i know i think it's
because the most the most concerning
thing too is he says i would have i
would have ended them i would have offed
them over dumb stuff too over petty
stuff too and daniel you saw the clip so
hashtag christian values if that's what
you think is representing christian
values then i have nothing else to say
well to be fair he says that that's what
he how he felt before he became
christian right yeah that's true he's
not saying
i mean i don't necessarily see anything
wrong with
that statement i mean that's a
personal revelation
about his own mental state and maybe he
you know had an anger problem
but if you know he's
moved past that because of christianity
okay i mean i i can't really fault him
for trying to improve
but
it's a interesting revelation about his
mental state in the past
so so let's talk about something a
little more uh related to religion islam
he mentioned that and he kind of used
this as a
what seemed to be a negative talking
point about islam that when you get a
quran you always have sub-notes you
cannot understand it on your own you
always need some kind of interpretation
needs to be interpreted
do you want to talk about a little bit
why do muslims need interpretation
well it's
revelation the quran is not meant to be
read like by itself in the abstract
um obviously every muslim can go and
open the quran and read it and
non-muslims can open the quran and read
it
and you will definitely
many have converted to islam
just by reading the quran by itself even
one of my close friends
who's a professor now at a university he
became muslim just because he opened the
mushroof and he started reading through
surat al-baqarah the longest chapter of
the quran he read surat al-fatiha then
he went to
the second chapter and about you know
maybe 60 verses within surat al-baqarah
like very early in the first juz he
said to himself i can't deny that this
is from god
like it just hit him so hard
um and he and he was a christian he was
like a
very devout believing christian he
believed in god and
he thought he was a christian and then
he read the quran and it just
became obvious it was obviously the
truth when when he read it and many
christians that i know who became muslim
have the same experience when they
opened the quran
some like i have another friend who
became muslim he was christian
and he just
opened the mustaf
and
basically
he landed on surat al-ikhlas
which every muslim learns as a child
say allah is one
that was the first thing he read from
the quran and it just hit him you know
really hard in the heart
that wow you know this is
because the quran is not like other
kinds of literature like you can read
the bible you can read
other kinds of scripture in hinduism or
you can read the talmud
which is the oral torah which jews also
believe is from god as revelation
given to moses
none of those those all read like you
know books that in literature that human
beings write
um but the quran
is just different like it has a
different feeling to it and
people even the enemies of islam will
will note it
and you can see this within the academic
study of the quran it's not really
poetry
because the arabs of of the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam in the
7th century and prior they had a long
tradition of poetry
um but the quran is not like that
and it's also not like prose like you're
relaying a story or you're relaying
historical events
or you're relaying like a myth like
mythology it's not like that either it's
just something completely unique and
completely different
and
this will strike the non-muslim the
atheist and
even christians so i think when he
you know noted like he clearly has
noticed like the quran is different he
wants to spin it as if it's a bad thing
but
what muslims know is that well it's
because it's unique because it's
actually from god it's not the inspired
word of god it's not you know like this
uh long convoluted history of the bible
with all of its revisions and edits and
contradictions
it's not like that it's something
unique it's something amazing it's a
miracle
so alhamdulillah that we're muslim and
we
have the this gift
and we're sharing it with the with the
world alhamdulillah
so something actually i've wanted to
discuss um to the audience to the people
especially christians when it comes to
like for example the bible versus the
quran a lot of christians presuppose the
bible is true especially people like
young dawn he said himself on the last
stream where everything kind of started
i don't need to defend the bible and
then when sheikh man asked
um you know where do you get your
beliefs from he says the bible he's like
well how do you know it's just breathing
and he's like i don't need to defend it
so i was like you know you can't you
know you can't claim such a thing but
they expect us to prove our religion and
go against all these weird accusations
they have so if somebody let's say young
don came on the stream and he's like
how do i know that the quran actually is
miraculous
how would you go about educating him on
that
well there's different aspects of the
miraculousness
of the quran but i mean first i think i
find it like hilarious that he says he
doesn't need to defend
the bible i think this is just something
that he like a talking point that he got
from his handlers like it's clearly
clear that he's being trained
if that's the kind of thing he's saying
so it's like okay we we're not like on
that stage of your training yet young
don like just if they bring up the bible
anything for them from the bible just
say you're not going to defend it like
that's such a
nonsensical answer yeah
uh but when it comes to the the quran um
there are different aspects to its
miraculousness um
one of
what a lot of people will talk about is
for example the
language of the quran and the eloquence
of the quran
within the quran
and this there are many
commentaries on this i think what really
was the most uh notable thing that in my
life
was you know i i went to harvard and for
my undergrad in college and there was a
christian arab here's lebanese
who was also in in the same class as me
freshman year
at harvard and we were talking about
religion and comparing the quran and the
bible
and he said you know his father is also
a christian lebanese christian
and who's like an expert in literature
and so he's talking about his father and
he admitted at one one point in our
conversation that his father actually
loves the quran
even though he's a christian he loved
the quran and i was like well why if
he's a christian
and he loves the quran why doesn't he
become muslim
and this lebanese guy was saying that
well he recognizes that the quran is
from god he recognizes that because why
wh why does he recognize that because of
the language
like he's an expert in literature
he knows that the quran like no one can
match no human being can match that
level of eloquence of the quran
and so he
for that reason believes that it's from
god he just can't accept it like for
personal reasons like something is
blocking him from accepting it as the
truth
so i thought that was very interesting
testimony testimony
i think that this uh miraculous nature
of the quran it's something that you
can't really express
or even a lot of muslims won't even be
able to recognize themselves because
most muslims are not going to reach that
level of expertise with the arabic
language
you can study arabic for years
and not reach a level of mastery to
appreciate all of the nuances that make
the quran the superior
as you get you know further and further
in your arabic studies you get more of a
sense of it
and you get more of a taste of it and
how the quran is different and superior
but so it's it's hard to convey that to
people who don't speak arabic or they
don't they haven't mastered arabic
or they you know they're just not
muslims
so
i i'm not sure if that's the best point
to really emphasize to
non-muslims i think one
aspect of the miraculousness of the
quran that we can
justify for non-muslims to be able to
verify themselves is the preservation of
the quran
and this is something that is unmatched
in any religion like no religion with
their scripture comes close
um other religions they can't really
attribute their books to the supposed
founders of their religion
there's no evidence there's no like hard
evidence
that for example you can date the oldest
biblical manuscripts
and they're just
you know when it comes to the new
testament it's like the earliest
manuscripts can only be dated to within
150 years after
uh jesus
150 years or when it comes to
moses and the old testament or the
hebrew bible
that's even you know it's they can't
even get within
uh a thousand years
of moses they can't they don't have any
manuscript
that exists that they know of that can
be dated to the time of when when moses
according to judaism purportedly lived
so if you can't get the manuscript or
you can't get the earliest manuscripts
anywhere close to the supposed founder
of the religion
then
how can you have confidence that the
book that you have
the hebrew bible is what actually came
from the founder of the religion how can
you tell that
um
or uh hinduism like you can't with the
vedas
the vedas you can't get the oldest
manuscripts are
thousands three thousand four thousand
years after the founders
allegedly of hinduism allegedly lived
and and wrote the vedas
so this is like there's no religion
that's even close but when it comes to
the quran
the oldest manuscripts of the quran
are dated academically
objectively to within the lifetime of
the prophet salallahu
that is that is significant why because
we can open those manuscripts
uh and read what they what's written
there and match that with what muslims
today
read and recite and teach of the quran
that is
huge that that is because if you think
that god sends revelation
right that's what christians believe
that's what jews believe
hindus have have a slightly different
understanding of revelation buddhists
have a slightly different understanding
of revelation but let's just focus on
judaism and christianity they believe
jews and christians believe that god
sends revelation in some form or fashion
whether it's inspired word of god or
tablets being sent to moses or whatever
god sends that revelation to guide
humanity
but if god is sending that revelation
wouldn't he preserve it like wouldn't it
be something that's
preserved up to this time
so that people can follow that
revelation and and practice it
the fact that that has not happened
in judaism and christianity is a is a
big mark against those religions
actually or those scriptures actually
being from
god
but in islam we actually meet like that
that bar
islam the quran actually meets that
basic requirement the basic logical
requirement for being like a true
religion in our times
uh how can you be a true religion and
have the scripture have the revelation
of god when you can't even source it to
the founder of the religion this the
alleged founder of the religion speaking
you know in academic terms yeah so islam
is the only religion that meets that
uh standard
so that's that's something miraculous
and and we're not even talking about
memorization
because that's a different whole
different aspect of it because we know
that the quran has been transmitted
primarily through rest through
memorization and recitation
and muslims have their children memorize
the entire quran my own children are
memorizing the quran we're trying to get
them to complete theirs
that's what preserves the quran
uh but if that's not enough for you we
also got the receipts
we also got you know all of the all the
script all the texts
the manuscripts the folios they've been
preserved they're in various museums
and they've been dated carbon dated to
within the lifetime of the prophet
salallahu sallam and there's also a lot
of geological discoveries because
muslims would write quran
not just on like um parchment or vellum
like
animal hide leather they would also
write on rock
they would also write on pottery or uh
they were
other places that
can last
you know over centuries and now
archaeologists are discovering like
these kinds of inc
carvings within stone in the arabian
peninsula and they can date those also
to within the lifetime of the prophet
sallallahu islam or very early after
and that's further proof and evidence
but you don't have anything analogous to
that within judaism
or christianity and definitely
definitely not the
vedic religions like hinduism and
buddhism and so forth yeah 100 100
and uh if that is not enough for someone
to accept islam that has to at least be
enough for someone like don to
have a huge doubt casted over his belief
and the question as to why he is a
christian and i think that's something
that's very uncomfortable for a lot of
people to ask themselves and to try and
sit down with themselves and answer it
but for any belief you have it is
necessary i want to expand on that point
a little bit
um just so it's a little more understood
most of the manuscripts for the new
testament
that we have are from the 9th century
the ninth century yeah
exactly
and anything we do have from like the
second century third century is like the
size of a credit card and the shape of a
triangle
so
like there's probably more information
on my credit card than there is on on
those
things
and there's this book i have here i
point out every single time i talk
you can't read it but it says the five
gospels it has the gospel of mark
matthew luke and john and also the
gospel of thomas which i know christians
say is not canonical but still a
historical document to some extent and
you might be wondering why am i bringing
out this giant book it's because they
took every single verse that is reported
in the gospels that jesus said and they
rank them
and they color code them as well
they put in red letters like this at the
top things jesus most likely said they
put in pink letters things he probably
said they put in gray letters things he
probably didn't say and they put in bold
black letters things jesus definitely
did not say it was a group of new
testament scholars who got together and
voted on every they voted on every
single verse in these five gospels and i
just want you to take a quick look and
tell me what color you see most of
black it's mostly black black black
black black you know why 95 of the
verses in here were graded black
by or were graded completely fabricated
and authentic by the jesus seminar
and other scholars new testament
scholars that is because
you cannot in any way shape or form
link the new testament
back to jesus christ peace and blessings
be upon him and adding to that point
with all the differing views
they had at the time
how would you know that this
articulation this understanding of jesus
was the accurate one you had the ebay
knights you had i think the monarchists
i think is the name
and you had subordinationists you have
unitarians as well amongst those groups
you have so many different groups of
people how do you know that this
co-equal eternal trinity that you have
today that came 300 years later and it
was voted upon
at the council of nicea how do you know
that is the correct understanding you
don't
and that i think is another big problem
that they have to deal with i can't
expand on it more but inshallah i think
we should move on i have some super
chats here quickly
i mean we don't even have to go back to
like the ebia knights and the marcia
knights yeah
because those were different uh groups
um you know within
two or three centuries of jesus
but
um what about all of the changes and
distortions to
uh christianity and christian christian
theology christology
uh
like in the past 200 years over the past
300 years or like this um young don
uh
he's
like following what evangelical
christianity like he's born again
christian like where what are the roots
of evangelical christianity
um and why should you be evangelical
christian as opposed to the hundreds of
other or thousands of other sects
with just in the modern day and there
are some huge differences like
between you know your conception of god
your conception of jesus
is jesus the
son of god is he co-eternal with god is
he this or that so
all of these are like major differences
in theology
um
that don't exist in islam like in islam
you can say oh what are the big
distinctions you have sunni and you have
shia
sunni
about oh does god have a son or does god
have like
different uh partners that he works with
or like we don't have those kinds of
uh distinctions in our very conception
of god himself
um so that's that's a big difference
between islam and yoga and christianity
for sure
100
100
and one last note i want to mention on
this topic is amongst different opinions
and i think we really are kind of
beating the dead horse here so we'll
move on after this maybe take some
questions and super chats but actually
there was a question earlier for you so
i'll read that out in a minute but um
there is actually
it's actually crazy if you think about
it not that we need this as muslims we
don't need this at all but just so
christians kind of understand the kind
of beliefs that were out there there was
an early century
uh early second century or let's just be
fair i say second century church father
named basilides
who iranius writes in his book against
heresies i can find the exact quote for
you if you want
that basilities believed that jesus was
not crucified and that simon
was switched out on the cross and he was
crucified in jesus place while jesus
rose to his father does that sound very
familiar to you does that sound familiar
to you this is second century church
father reported by iranius in his book
the great book
against heresies where he talked about i
think the uh ib nights and a bunch of
other groups as well
this conception or this this belief
was articulated by a second century
church father
when islam came in seventh century
arabia and the process of had no access
to even the bible the five the four
gospels you have today let alone the
work of one random church father in the
second century
like
just to know that historically that kind
of belief was there to begin with from a
church father in the second century
sit with that think about it i'm going
to read this question i'm going to take
a two minute break for myself
unless you guys have anything you want
to add before i read this question
no i just want to say denying that is
like denying any rationale like there's
there's nothing to say after that yeah
yeah but uh i mean you can't really
expect unfortunately with these
christian apologists you can't expect
any kind of consistency
um it's just really they
will go to all kinds of lengths to deny
like the obvious contradictions the
obvious inconsistencies on any of these
issues that we're talking about whether
we're talking about like violence
whether they're talking about like
marriage like minor marriage we're
talking about authenticity of text
whether we're talking about theology
preservation of scripture
like they really have nothing that they
can criticize islam with and
i mean this is a big
point also that we should
make is that well why are like in in
an earlier clip
uh this young don is saying that islam
is like the religion of satan
um islam is
muslims are the foot soldiers of of
satan and i find that so funny when you
have a christian saying that
and why do they say that why are they
focused on islam because in the whole
world there are only two religions that
have
any kind of positive understanding of
jesus christ
one is christianity and the other is
islam
all other religions are either neutral
with with regard to christianity or they
actually
demonized jesus christ
um
and
that religion is judaism so
there there are
there's at least one religion that
actually has demonized jesus christ and
like very
disturbing and shocking ways what they
write about jesus in their texts but
these christians want to criticize
muslims and islam even though we have
like the most positive
view of jesus christ so how does that
make any sense how how can you claim to
be consistent when you want to demonize
islam but you have nothing to say about
these other religions that are either
neutral like they think that christ was
just a random nobody
or they think that he was like a
sorcerer polytheist spawn of uh of satan
like you have nothing to say about those
religions but you want to focus on islam
i'll tell you why i'll give you the
reason it's because
uh islam is the only religion that
has not liberalized islam is the only
religion that hasn't sold out to like
the modern liberal
world yeah whereas all of these other
religions like hinduism judaism buddhism
uh even confucianism
shintoism they've all liberalized
they've all adopted these kinds this
liberal understanding of human value
human rights etc and islam is the only
holdout islam is the only religion that
says no we're not going to sell out our
religion we're not going to change we're
not going to change our teachings we're
not going to distort it because why
because we know it's from god and we're
going to practice it
you guys are changing so christians on
some level either explicitly or
especially these apologists they
recognize that on some level and they
see islam as a threat like islam if you
compare christianity in its reformed
modernized liberalized secularized form
today
to islam it's it's obvious that
christians have sold out
christians have restored their teachings
and there's a there's like all the
receipts are there when we when you look
at the 19th century at the beginning of
the enlightenment and the pressure that
was put on the church the catholic
church as well as protestants as well as
orthodox to update and change their
teachings to outlaw certain things
that historical record is all there
so this this
makes them feel threatened it makes them
feel like they have to go after the big
boys you know
muslims they have to go after the you
know the true religion they don't go
after hinduism they don't go after
judaism they don't go after buddhism
because those they're all in one group
like a bunch of liberalized reformed
religions islam is the last man standing
so that's
it's obvious why they will focus their
energy and their anger hatred and
jealousy on muslims and islam yeah 100
that is that is very true and it's
unfortunate but uh alhamdulillah i think
muslims are resilient enough you know
to uh to withstand that and it's funny
because you you mentioned something and
answered the question that somebody
asked before i got a chance to read it
out they said question for daniel in
contemporary society do you think
christianity is learning more and more
uh is is leaning more and more towards
secular thinking and i think you
completely answered that wholeheartedly
so i think uh masood brother you got
your answer there inshaallah
i am going to take a 2 minute break
myself you guys insha allah will
continue and uh continue to educate the
viewers here in charlotte one question i
want to ask daniel because we didn't get
a chance to actually fully watch the
clip with you here live we know that you
took a look at it earlier on uh while
i'm gone
you and i can talk about what were your
initial reactions to it you know what
were your initial thoughts when you
heard some of the claims of maybe the
things we get a chance to discuss with
you
uh yeah sure um and daniel bro you could
hear me right yeah i can hear you okay
uh yeah i think that
i mean there are a lot of things that
uh that i saw from the clip like he's
bringing up the age of aisha
radiology it's like a standard christian
bulimic but it's like such a again like
a weak claim because they have the same
thing in the bible like even
more explicit
and i mean i think that when it comes to
the age of aisha like we have to be
clear like
yeah there might be some kind of
question about okay was she
seven or six or
nine or ten
but there's no actual uh
view or opinion in the in the tradition
the islamic tradition that says she was
like 18 or 17.
uh that's a 100 modern view
so i think we have to be like very clear
about that like okay
just because it's not like
there's not like a birth certificate
that says that aisha was born on this
month on this day and this year then
therefore it's open she could have been
uh much older no like no one seriously
thought that she was much older like
that's generally the age range
but again like this is not
an issue it's not an issue like uh in
the clip
the young don is saying that oh well
muslims have no problem with minor
marriage
uh because they have satan in their
hearts or jesus has not entered their
hearts i think is what he said
so i mean if that's the case then
jesus was not in the heart of christians
themselves
because christians throughout history
accepted uh minor marriage and practiced
minor marriage throughout their
societies throughout their um throughout
europe minor marriage was practiced and
even in canon law canon law which is
um you know the most like it's the
analog to fill
in islam like a fake tradition but in
canon law within christianity
um the age of consent was just 12 years
old
so
that like the same kind of concept of
minor marriage
daughters being married off young
that is something that has been
practiced by christians by jews by
muslims by pretty much every single
civilization
prior to
modern liberal reforms have have
practiced this
um so
yeah i just have a hard time
understanding like what is their
uh complaint like okay
if you want to just take
whatever you believe now like
young don
himself he converted right so he
accepted an entire religion that
means that he for many years of his life
was living completely ignorant about
certain things he was just a product of
his culture product of social forces
around him and then he discovered this
religion and he became christian
so that should give him in a sense that
you can be very wrong
about the nature of
reality for large portions of your life
before you discover something that you
then believe is true
and we should all have this kind of
sense that a lot of the things in the
world around us
that we
that seem to be true that seem to be
right that seem to be moral
uh may actually turn out to be wrong
might turn out to be unjust may turn out
to be immoral
and other things that we thought were
immoral might turn out to be perfectly
fine and moral
that that's what it means to be like a
humble person or to understand that
we to a certain extent everyone is the
product of their environment and a
product of their culture so this idea
that it's some kind of
huge moral injustice it's like a crime
uh like it's completely oppressive and
abusive
for a man to marry a
pubescent minor
at those age at those ages that's
something that is purely a product of
the past
not even necessarily 200 years but more
like 100 years or 50 years in one
particular part of the world
so
it's like a very
when i can more understand atheists
making this type of argument against
islam
um because they just believe in the
morality of the now
like whatever happens now whatever we
believe now according to the liberal
state
okay for a hundred years
muslims christians atheists believe that
sex between two men is completely
immoral and completely wrong but now in
the past 10 years we we believe that
it's a beautiful thing that we should
all celebrate
like that change
is only 10 years
old so if you're an atheist and you
really believe that morality works like
that like it can constantly update okay
that's a separate discussion and there
are separate arguments that you can make
against that but if you're a christian
you don't believe
in that right if you're a christian you
don't believe that values are just
constantly updating you believe in a
tradition you believe in
you know the morality of prior
christians whether it's like the early
church fathers or whether it's like the
the papal tradition or the catholic
church or the orthodox church you
believe in a tradition
so you can't just make
judgments on the basis of your cultural
milieu like your cultural context and
sensibilities that have only come onto
the scene now within the past 10 years
or 50 years or 100 years you have to
look at the entire history you have to
look at the entire tradition and you
have to stand by that to a certain
extent and defend it because if you
start saying that no
this is something so immoral and so
wrong this kind of practice of minor
marriage then you're basically saying
that your entire
uh history is full of pedophiles
your entire religion is a is a religion
of
you know pedophiles because they were
practicing this
so an atheist like atheists are fine
with throwing the entire
past like all of this history under the
bus
they're fine with that
that has its own like problems and
irrationality
uh but christians
how can you make that kind of argument
it's so it's completely self-defeating
but they just don't want to admit it
like
yeah it's like it's a joke basically
like these kinds of christian
apologetics is just a joke like one joke
after another it's
and i've debated christians before and
um like david wood was probably the
biggest apologist i debated and you just
can't keep up with the contradictions
that
they spew
yeah and uh just for everyone's
reference here you can find the debate
between daniel hakichu and david wood
online you can find debates between him
and many other people whether they be
christians or atheists or liberal
secularists whatever it might be you can
find them online you can also find just
this for like young don you can find
sheikh uthman
versus someone you want to watch after
discussing sheikh man david wood you can
find that debate or those debates online
as well you can find many muslims
discussing with even even muhammad hijab
clowning david yeah many muslims shabir
ali many many muslims
debating all three of the people you you
mentioned a pus david wood nabil qureshi
shabir ali debated nabil kreshi uh he
passed away so like there's no recent
debates but you know before he passed
away you see the debates there you see
david wood uh debated by muhammad hijab
man i believe denna kishore also debated
against did you debate against a-pus or
was he too scared to do that yeah so
that happened yeah yeah he started
calling it like pikachu and that stuff
because my man had a whole mental
breakdown in the thing with daniel
yeah and um if if you think these people
are good to listen to okay go watch the
debates go watch debates do a live
reaction actually do a live reaction
because i know you won't react to this
life
uh and then see if you you know can
defend whatever they're saying then when
they're in front of a muslim okay
something amazing
oh sorry real quick just a note about
shabirani because a lot of muslims will
follow his debates
but actually he has like a lot of messed
up views like islamically
so i would like be careful just watch it
you can watch his debate if you want i
mean other people have debated
just as good or better than him against
christians but just know in the back of
your mind that he's like
definitely not a orthodox muslim like he
has all kinds of deviant views yeah are
you talking about like like a recent
shabir ali or like
decade two ago shibuya ali because i
think i feel like those are two
different
beliefs well he's still he's still
debating now like he just had a debate
with david with a couple of weeks ago i
think wow i was not talking about that i
was talking about the the one against i
think came into bill crush like years
ago on the trinity
versus tahit i think that's what it was
but uh i i'm aware of of what you're
talking about some of his um his his
views i don't uh
and you know one one thing i wanted to
say too is in christianity there's a
belief that priests
cannot have
intercourse daniel you can correct me if
i'm wrong
yeah within the catholic church
yeah within the catholic church a lot of
them they talk about how they're married
to god a lot of the the nuns too and
they can't have intimacy so it's
self-imposed celibacy
but the result of the self-imposed
celibacy this this alone should prove
it's not from god ramen you can pull up
the link that i i sent you
but this alone can prove that it's not
from god because
if allah created us
he understands us he understands our
nature he understands that we as men and
women have needs very primal needs
and imposing celibacy is going to do
more harm than good
now in islam we restrict that to our
wives and permissible outlets
and for women they're husbands but if
you look at this you just just pull it
up bro it's it's disgusting
here
it's on the screen now
asked me to log in but i won't
yeah if you could read it just that's
bless all right um
so the the title says
french catholic church personnel
sexually abused 330
000 miners probe fines this is the wall
street journal which i don't have a
subscription to so i can only read the
title
yeah i think that um
there's definitely an issue there with
with celibacy and
whether that breeds hypocrisy
um because it's like such a
unnatural thing
um to require celibacy um
so
i think a lot of christian groups though
will criticize catholicism for that
um so it's not universal across
christianity
we just have to note that to be fair and
i also don't
want to like it's obviously appalling
like the amount of child abuse
within the catholic church
um you'll also find it in other
religions
and you'll also find it in secular
institutions
um so if we look at the rates of child
abuse and molestation
when it comes to
um like just public schools
um
it's more than the catholic church
i think
it's comparable in terms of like the
total amount is is greater
but the actual rate you know per capita
or whatever is
is equal or more maybe
so i don't have the stats off the top of
my head
but i mean because i don't want
i think that we can criticize
christianity for a lot of things and we
want to be like principled about it but
we also have to recognize that
um the secular system and liberalism is
attacking
all religions
um is attacking and is basically trying
to stamp out religion
and
that again i'm not trying to defend the
catholic church
but we have to kind of recognize that
there is an attempt to subvert the
catholic tradition and
um orthodox christianity and those same
forces are used and those same kind of
arguments are used against muslims
so is it the case that you know some
muslim somewhere has committed a crime
like against a child
yeah of course that's that has happened
is that a reason to you know destroy or
to undermine
our mosques our masajid or our islamic
schools or you know different kinds of
institutions where we teach children
that's what they're trying to do that's
what these liberals are trying to do
with madrasas with mosques masajit
islamic schools
they want to kind of point this finger
and say that oh look someone got abused
that means the whole thing is corrupt
that means the whole thing has to be
shut down
and you have to send your kids to the
secular schooling the secular
institutions the secular day care
but they
you know downplay or hide the fact that
at these secular institutions at these
daycare centers let's talk about abuse
and molestation in these secular
institutions and public schools every
other day like you can find like some
kind of incident in the local news
happening where a teacher molested a
child
it's not it's not even it's not
something rare
so
like
we should just be like very fair and
even-handed not to defend like
the catholic church or like the cover-up
of abuse because that's also a factor
like they've they've covered up a lot of
this these molecular cases or they've
like transferred different priests
to different locations instead of
holding them accountable for their abuse
but you know let's also keep in mind the
broader factors so that we have like a
more
nuanced critique of like what's
happening
no that was well said
okay and brother daniel is there
anything else that you want to get out
before we wrap up the stream
yeah sure uh thanks so much for having
me on it's like a pleasure i hope i
didn't like talk too much
no no it was perfect it was it was good
it was necessary and may allah bless you
anyone that made it this far smash the
like button head over to the muslim
skeptic one more time it's the muslim
skeptic three words that's brother
daniel
channel and all the links are going to
be in the description anyway rami
anything you want to say wait one thing
i want to say sorry around go for it uh
i think that
like i think that there's
a benefit
to
someone like young don
becoming more religious becoming like
christian and
even attacking islam there i know it's
it's bad uh it's bottle it's like real
nonsense that he's spewing but there is
a silver lining like there is a positive
what is that the positive is that
muslims also step up their game
and more muslims are like
you know
interested in studying like these
details about the quran compared to the
bible about looking at theology looking
at akita basically stepping up our game
that's like a huge benefit and it's much
better than like young don being like
just this musician
and making youtube videos and like
promoting uh secularism purely and
muslims following that
and being fans of that instead muslims
are now like
uh you know stepping up their game
becoming more religious like that's
actually something that people
experience muslims experience like oh
you want to insult islam well i'm going
to be even a better muslim i'm going to
pray more i'm going to you know do more
sunnah i'm going to do read more quran
and there's that this kind of hima that
muslims have as a reaction so i think
it's
overall like it might seem contradictory
but
i want to it would be great i'd much
rather see more musicians more like uh
youtubers and entertainers become
religious christians
that is going to help like that i think
has a positive impact
on muslims
to react and especially when this with
this young don he's not like
spreading this message oh everyone's the
same all religions are the same we need
to hold hands and sing kumbaya it's
actually better that he's attacking
islam and he's saying you know he's
saying this nonsense
so that's maybe that's like my my
perspective but that's how i feel yeah
and i mean you you actually find this a
lot whenever there's like some kind of
an attack or or any big news i do with
islam even if it's in a negative light
you find a lot of people look into it
afterwards like um after the event in i
think 2001 i won't say what it is but it
has
one number slash another number i'm not
trying to get the platforms right now uh
you know in minecraft that's where it
happened a lot of people looked into
islam afterwards i got the one from
sneko a lot of people looked into islam
afterwards you find a lot of people
actually became muslim after looking
this time afterwards um so i think this
insha allah has and will benefit
literally thousands of people
alhamdulillah we've consistently had uh
close or over to 2000 viewers actively
so i think this has been amazing one
last
super chat i'm going to read before we
end the stream when westerners
vacations to their countries is well
documented
they
use little girls and bullies all the
time
all the vacation destinations have
receipts it's actually very true
unfortunately we won't talk about it too
much um
we'll save it for another time
insha'allah but with that being said
daniel's always nice having you everyone
check out our episode i think we had two
actually done with brother daniel uh in
the early conception of our channel
actually so he was an og uh from the
beginning something bro that was like a
year ago yeah yeah it's been a long time
ago
so everyone check those out subscribe to
daniel the muslim skeptic and um check
out his website musk the muslim
skeptic.com correct
yep muslimskeptic.com.com
bro listen super important thing to
piggyback off of what brother daniel
said
this
video is not just intended to
take non-muslims out of ignorance but to
empower muslims too
and to give them knowledge to give them
a lens that they might not have seen or
studied yet and that's why it's
absolutely imperative to anyone that
made it this far please share the video
wallahi not for us to get more subs or
this video to get anything else but if
everyone can share it to five people
just imagine how much you can have how
many muslims can be empowered and how
many non-muslims can slip out of
ignorance that's it share this video
like and at the end of the links in the
description watch the muslim skeptic
watch one message foundation we're all
trying to do the same thing and at the
end of the day we just want you guys to
come to the truth that's it
one hundred percent
fake questions
may allah bless you inshallah hopefully
we can do this again soon
inshallah
right so
we're about to end this off thank you
all very much for the super chats i
apologize i could not read all of them
but we do sincerely sincerely appreciate
it may allah make sure you guys help the
channel uh keep going keep running and
inshallah as we grow um honestly
donating is one thing but spreading the
video and spreading our channel is is a
whole other thing we can insha allah get
bigger
and better um
guests on here inshallah to help spread
the truth of islam
bigger platform bigger guests and not
just muslim muslims as well so we can
have more of these discussions about
islam with people who are sincere
inshallah we'll be doing sneaker part
two eventually and uh again thank you
all for the super chat
honestly fired bro
and guys listen super chats help out
they help us tremendously youtube
doesn't pay us as much as you guys think
helps us continue our work but
liking sharing commenting that helps us
more than you guys think and if you
can't do that just make dua for us
institute please keep us in your diwas
make dua that we keep spreading the dean
of allah not making mistakes staying
steadfast gaining knowledge ourselves
and inshallah look forward to in a week
from now on saturday
seven days from now you will see an
episode with
sister muslim brooklyn who is an
american
river who literally grew up in the
midwest and accepted islam in a small
town i believe she said there was not
more than 900 people
and
subhanallah was a wonderful story so
stay tuned for that inshaallah and with
that being said i think it's safe to end
it off here
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh